tous les essais avaient été décidés
avant que la moindre réunion du conseil
scientifique
il était question que du raid m6 viré du
lopinavir jamais l'hydroxyde latine qui
était le seul pour lequel on avait des
données préliminaires et qu' il n'y a
jamais eu d'organisation c'est le comité
scientifique n'a pas été c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles je me suis mis
en retrait de ce conseil scientifique
ce conseil scientifique n'a jamais
piloté quoi que ce soit par recherche
locaux vides rien et donc qui sait qui a
apporté les données pour savoir que les
enfants n'étaient pas affectés c'est
nous toutes les données vous avez là ça
me fait ça m'amuse beaucoup que les gens
parlent de maintenant qui découvre que
les ct n'ont pas tous la même valeur
ça fait deux mois et demi qu'on l'a
écrit non quand même donc le débat il
est cette semaine
d'accord donc ça c'est des choses que le
pilotage de l'état aurait dû faire
aurait dû dire écoutez dites nous
quelles sont les limites du s'étaient
dites nous quelle est l'incidence des
différentes couches de populations dites
nous quelle est l'incidence chez les
patients symptomatiques et
asymptomatiques
ça c'est du pilotage d'accord et ce
pilotage
c'est le conseil scientifique et de le
faire et je peux vous le dire j'ai écrit
très tôt en disant écoutez ce conseil
scientifique ne peut pas piloter une
recherche de crise
j'ai fait des propositions dont je me
suis au thé parce que je je je pensais
que je continue à penser que plus utile
à faire ça sur place parce quelle
décision prendre tous les jours et que
je me tends à tort ou à raison capable
de le faire mais j'ai proposé des gens
qui faisait des centaines de milliers de
pcr jeu pour dire j'ai proposé aux
portes de toulouse et celui de créteil
j'ai proposé des gens qui connaissaient
parfaitement la pharmacopée la
pharmacologie j'aurais jamais validé les
autres cyclos qui est un poison mortel
donc il y avait des gens qui étaient
capables de mener une véritable
politique scientifique ce conseil
scientifique n'était pas fait de gens
qui étaient capables de mener une
politique scientifique